so what's stopping us from moving in the
fourth dimension well maybe it is that
the fourth dimension is so small that
our movement in it is unnoticeable this
is a cylinder and for creatures that
live on the surface of the cylinder they
live in a two-dimensional curved space
if we then shrank it to be really really
small it might appear as a
one-dimensional line even though it is
really a two-dimensional curved space
and home to our 2D friend if I saw my
chalkboard from very far away I might
think that it is flat and
two-dimensional but up close I can see
that it also has depth maybe the fourth
dimension is also hiding somewhere very
small or maybe we're just too far away
to see it